o xerez
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e aí galera que aceite meu canal do bom
você ea galera votar no ps xlsx você não
sabe o maior evento de outubro do brasil
vai falar que é frágil e com cielo
gustavo carletto ao lado muito ingênuo
tempo depois são paulo até hoje é dia
das crianças está no promoção quem
comprar o ingresso e primeiro longa
descrição do vídeo dia das crianças
deles é muito bom a gente sabe ainda das
crianças nem pela data é pelas fotos das
pessoas do facebook agora dia da criança
tem que trocar minho foto e colocando
quando eu era bebê e mixar o facebook
não sabia das crianças é halloween às
vezes deus faz você me conhecer desse
tamanho para lhe poupar de ver aquela
imagem de quando eu era criança eu
poupei as pessoas de fazerem negócio
trocar a foto de perfil por uma foto da
criança é a coisa mais bonita que saiu
quando eu nasci pra atuar sempre no
teatro foi nacif feito era criança eu
competi um ano dois anos de idade e
estava até mais bonito e marcou nasci eu
era gay
o doutor me puxou e parou e olhou pra
mim isso aqui vai latir certeza não
entregou pra mamãe mamãe olhou olhou pro
doutor doutor seu batom com força mas
sem criança é bom quando você é criança
bem mais leve que a cor que eu mais
gostava quando era criança brincar
paulistas qual eu estudei em escola
pública escola pública é o seguinte
quando chegou livre à remessa de livro
novo que vem mas tem aquele livro velho
usado por uns quatro anos ea chutar
rapei dar a cuspir e é todo desenhar e
criança okami ele vira a página está
aqui cheio de cálculo aqui no cantinho
tem um quadradinho que ele vê um lugar
ideal a desenhar um pique pique tupé
kahwaji mil porque ela dezembro porque
só ela conhece a falar o seguinte ela
deve ser um triângulo dá uma boa
vantagem no meio e bótons cabelo aqui ó
pode chegar a criança pergunta meu filme
foi você já viu no mundo um prefeito
calvo entender por quê desenhou uma
borboleta uma lagar num elefante não
desejam preguiça ensino integral por que
desenha um homem com a roupa que vem até
que a rodovia até que momento já meu
amigo quem quer porque quer usar o velho
chega professor olha que os livros
i ea criança pode queimar tudo bom dia
que a dg burgo é tocada estatuto é que
ele chutava a quem chama dona campo do
meu blackeberry lama e à medida que a
criança vai crescer nessas linhas vão
ficando mais pesado e autarca para a
vitamina como duas primas primeiro limão
com do irmão ele não é violento como teu
pai perguntou ela é ser pesado nem
completar você percebe que a criança
deixou de ser criança quando ela pára de
rima as coisas a posição burro e rolimã
quanto o irmão foi muito a mãe dela
vagabunda roubar um paradigma fica
pesado eu estou pesado falar da mãe para
uma criança falou da mãe não acho
interessante que xinga o pai meu amigo
pode acabar o pai pode chamar de lixo
tóxico ou mano tranquilo agora falou da
mãe
achei bom o etoo é de tatuar será
testada na época do carai meu pai que
era roubado e wake viagem velha leve
atrapalha já de baile vai todo mundo que
pode bater o seu pai e filho também de
vagabunda estou muito a par e minha mãe
que não votar o play em agosto ver e
guardar muitos outros que vêm agora
também a pagar tua mãe da rapariga
o negócio vai agora vem admite que o
menino vira um cão e crianças nada
engraçado que chora e crianças chorando
ele quer falar o transmitiu uma mensagem
mais gente não consegue entender o que
está acontecendo aqui pedir ficou em 69
kv que chegou onde chegou a minha hora
ninguém tem nada que me fala a gente
pensou eu pode sim está tão nervoso que
não consegue nem falar mas não é ali é
uma língua própria das crianças sós
criança entende pode prestar atenção
bote duas crianças a chorar junto com
ela sim tem o verde não chegou a ficar
nem quanto vai quem chegou foi ganho na
hora que ele permite falar outra bakun
nem foi o que chegou de facão de oyó
i foi na água turva e também agora vou
dizer como você pode não acreditar nesse
negócio de espírito de encostar que
existe um encosto na nossa vida chamado
irmão menor o irmão menor poder nas que
começa a crescer o pai só deixa você
sair se você levar o diário do irmão
menor e você não quer levar o irmão
menor o que você quer fazer coisas
ilícitas o irmão menor num certo essas
coisas não são parceiros há porque se
eles vêem fazendo alguma coisa ali é a
chance de dominar a gente como um
escravo por esta minha mãe está lavando
a louça pq brunch que não gosta você já
começa a escutar aquela musiquinha do
satanás a ehta vou dizer ei está vou de
ver a lei provavelmente vai ter que
lavar roupa de buscar água a comida na
boca irmão menor não vim para fazer você
se sentir melhor você nunca vai ver o
irmão menor chegando pode dizer assim
calma que tudo vai dar certo não ele só
diz assim sabe que quando chegar vai
moer mas é o que eu sempre digo às vezes
é quem gosta de criança de criança
correr mais é só alegria maior fase da
vida da gente que não volta
todo mundo quer criança que é adulto e
quando você é adulto que você chega
aquela responsabilidade com as contas a
pagar sequer voltar a ser criança não
tem mais se você é criança e você tem um
irmão que é pequeno se você tem um
sobrinho tem alguma criança perde você
deixa ela ser criança deixe brincar na
lama acompanha o crescimento porque é
uma coisa que você nunca vai voltar no
tempo e perdeu o crescimento do irmão ou
um filho de um sobrinho que sei lá o que
seja a dia da festa pelo dia das
crianças se você gostou desse vídeo
esquece clicarem gostei aqui no youtube
só pra ninguém quer sair sem da light
clique gostei de que esse rick joguei lá
no facebook então se você viu esse link
vídeo novo sei lá no facebook não
esquece que querem curtir lá e marcar o
seu amigo nos comentários
ele lembra da infância eu quero que você
comente aqui no youtube também
o que é que você mais gostava quando
você era criança se inscreve no canal
nunca perder de novo tamo junto é nóis
valeu equipe e